pfss nous enfrainene des matinées un peu
chargées donc on débute de bon heure en
tous les cas un grand merci Madame THB
donc pour votre présence donc nous
allons vous auditionner je rappelle que
la directrice des risques professionnel
de la Caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie et donc nous allons vous écouter
très naturellement concernant le le
financement notamment et j'indique
d'ailleurs que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
ise en direct sur le site du Sénat et
bien entendu disponible la demande alors
nous allons bien entendu commencer par
quelques propos liminire pour avoir
votre vision notamment sur la branche
ATMP puis ensuite nous demanderons alors
notre rapporteur Marie-Pierre rich est
absente ce matin mais je sais que Pascal
guner sera là pour poser un certain
nombre de questions que nous avons
préparé
concernant concernant la branche et
ensuite nous donnerons la parole à
l'ensemble de nos commissaires ici
présents d'accord autour de tout ça vous
connaissez exercice depuis quelques
années madame c'est à
vous merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs bonjour
Effectivement propos liminire mais je
serai je serai Brè quelques mots sur la
branche accè en travail et maladie
professionnelle vous le savez sur la
situation financière de la branche
présente une situation durablement
positive depuis plus de 10 ans exception
faite de l'année 2020 et des
conséquences de la crise de la crise
sanitaire donc le sol de la branche en
2022 est à 1 milliard 6 1 milliard 9 en
2023 en lien évidemment avec
l'augmentation des recettes c'est-à-dire
des cotisations assis sur la masse
salariale + 7 % ou + 6 %
euh du côté de la sinistralité des
actions de travail et maladie
professionnelle du régime général c'est
une situation tendantielle plutôt à la
baisse ces 10 dernières années en tout
cas depuis les années 2010 même si les
dépenses pour la branche reste reste
dynamique en lien avec la croissance des
salaires sur lesquels son sont assises
les indemnités journalières pour
l'incapacité temporaire que nous
indemnisons et les rentes pour
l'incapacité permanente avec également
des revalorisations annuelles et par
exemple une revalorisation anticipée de
l'inflation liée à l'inflation 2022
alors à contrario les dépenses également
remboursées par la branche couvrent
aussi les dépenses liées à la miande qui
est évidemment en repliis tendantielle
au regard du rapport entre les entrées
et les sorties et également un point
tradition inellement important dans ce
PLFSS qui est le reversement de la
branche à la branche maladie pour
compenser la sous-déclaration en lien
avec les évaluations réalisées par la
commission qui se réunira d'ailleurs de
nouveau en
2024 pour la situation particulièrement
liée à 2024 ce que l'on peut noter c'est
que les dépenses sont sont restent à la
hausse alors en lien avec l'ONDAM auquel
souscrivent les indemnités journalières
à TMP mais aussi en lien avec de
nouvelles dépenses qui sont liées à la
mise en œuvre du de de la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale
rectificative portant réforme des
retraitees avec la création d'un fond
d'investissement pour la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle qui repose sur
les les fonds de la branche accent de
travail et maladie professionnelle pour
la prévention des des risques
ergonomiques et qui est un dispositif
qui est en train de se de se créer et
qui sera financé en année pleine à
partir de 2024 à hauteur de 200 million
d'euros par an et également lien cette
augmentation des dépenses avec un
élargissement des conditions d'accès au
comptees professionnel de prévention qui
est également géré par la branche accent
de travail et maladie professionnelle
avec de nouveaux usages ou des
abaissements de seuil qui en facilitent
l'accès et également une mesure liée à
la retraite pour incapacité permanente
donc ces financements de de dépenses
supplémentaires pour la branche sont
bien présent au sein de ce de ce PLFSS
pour
2024 un petit mot également euh euh d'un
article qui concerne très spécifiquement
la branche qui est l'article
39 qui cherche à répondre à une question
de fond sur quels sont les préjudices
indemnisés par les rentes acent de
travail et maladie
professionnelles en lien avec évidemment
une jurisprudence de la Cour de
cassation de début d'année 23 en lien
avec un accord national
interprofessionnel également signé par
les partenaires sociaux et représenté
évidemment au sein de la gouvernance
ATMP de la de la branche et c'est un
article important pour la branche
puisqu'il détermine Infiné le niveau
d'indemnisation qui s'appliquera à peu
près 30000 nouveaux rentiers d'un
capacités permanentees qui sont
indemnisé par la rente chaque
année cet article prévoit une
indemnisation à la hausse avec un
engagement du Gouvernement sur ce point
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
l'article figure dans ce dans ce
PLFSS en laissant pour
autant un temps de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux sur les modalités
concrètes les bar à définir pour prévoir
ces modalités d'indemnisation à la
hausse donc il y a un temps de de 2024
qui doit être consacré en application de
cet article aux travaux avec les
partenaires sociaux et cette
indamnisation à la hausse s'explique par
dorénavant l'intégration selon cet
article de l'indemnisation de préjudices
dysfonctionnels c'est-à-dire les
préjudices extra
professionnels qui seraient selon cet
article de rénavant intégré à la nature
dual de la rente donc pour tous les
rentill donc il y a un champ important
devant nous euh en lien avec cette
indemnisation de la rente c'est un
chantier qui sera évidemment important
sur l'incapacité l'indemnisation de
l'incapacité permanente de la branche
ATMP évidemment en terme d'actualité et
j'en finirai là avec la gouvernance de
la branche action travail et maladie
professionnelle nous travaillons
activement à l'élaboration de la
convention d'objectif et de gestion que
comme toutes les branches de la sécurité
sociale la branche ATMP contractualise
avec les services de l'État pour les 5
ans à venir et donc qui porte de
nouveaux projets et évidemment les
moyens de fonctionnement de la branche
je m'en tiendrai là et je suis à votre
disposition évidemment pour vos
questions merci Madame la Directrice en
tous les cas nous avons entendu les
évolutions et puis vous êtes parti de
ceux qui vous avez la gestion d'un
budget qui est excédentaire donc voilà
donc on vous sent plus détendu par
rapport à nombre de vos collègues qui
ont parfois des sujets un peu plus
difficiles voilà mais quoi qu'il en soit
on a on a regarde de très près
l'évolution et je vais tout de suite
donner la la parole donc à Madame gruni
qui va poser les questions pour notre
rapporteur marie-pierrecher
Pascal merci monsieur le Président
madameme la directrice donc je m'exprime
effectivement au nom de Marie-Pierre
Richer retenu au bureau du Sénat mais
j'étais la rapporteur précédemment de
cette branche alors comme l'an dernier
donc le PLFSS pour 2024 affiche une
trajectoire accidentaire vous avait dit
tous les ans jusqu'en 2027 pour la
branche ATMP et alors que la branche
atteindra un acccédent cumulé de 12,5
milliards d'euros en 2027 prouvant par
la même la déconnexion entre ces
recettes et ses charges à long terme
quelles pistes sont-elles étudi pour
procéder à un
rééquilibrage le rapport sur la santé
des femmes au travail que ma collègue
Marie-Pierre Richer a co-écrit avec ses
collègues Laurence Rossignol Annique
jacquem et notre ancienne collè è
Laurence Cohen fait état d'une
augmentation de 42 % des accidents du
travail subis par les femmes entre 2001
et 2019 alors que ce chiffre a baissé de
27 % pour les hommes sur la même période
quels projets sont à l'étude pour enfin
accélérer les actions de prévention dans
les secteurs d'activités accidentog gène
et féminisé le médico-social la santé
l'entretien
ou non le PLFSS propose de fixer à 1,2
milliards d'euros pour 2024 le montant
du transfert opéré au titre de la
sous-reconnaissance des ATMP à la
branche maladie après 1,1 milliards
d'euros en 2022 et 1 milliard d'euros
les années précédentes vous savez que
c'est quelque chose qui nous crispe
particulièrement alors comment
expliquez-vous que le montant de ce
transfert n'est fait qu'augmenté depuis
sa mise en œuvre en
1997 cette augmentation ne conduit-elle
pas à nier les efforts substantiels
réalisé par tous les acteurs et en
premier lieu bien sûr les entreprises
pour lutter contre la sous-déclaration
et favoriser la prévention moi
j'ajouterais aussi on a interrogé
laacnam la semaine dernière euh
normalement il y avait a priori
l'information qui a été faite auprès des
médecins mais je pense que l'information
en fait on n tient pas compte puisqu'on
continue à augmenter ce prélèvement sur
sur sur la branche et et il y a d'autres
pistes on pourrait soit baisser les
cotisations pour saluer les efforts mais
plutôt toujours en fait mettre plutôt C
ce milliard d'euros dépassé aujourd'hui
sur toujours la prévention alors ensuite
conformément au souhait exprimé par les
partenaires sociaux dans l'année du 15
mai 2023 le PLFSS réforme le mode de
calcul de la rente viagère
ATMP pour confirmer sa nature duale et
expliciter que la rente ATMP a vocation
à financer tant le préjudice économique
que le déficit fonctionnel permanent
cette mesure suscite d'importantes
craintes de la part des accidentés du du
travail la FNAT évoque par exemple une
trahison pour les victimes d'atmp
estimant que cette réforme sera
défavorable aux victimes qu'avez-vous à
répondre à ces observations et comment
selon vous la réforme du mode de calcul
des rentes va-t-elle si elle était
adoptée influer sur le niveau
d'indemnisation des victimes enfin la
dernière question face à la sinistralité
particulièrement élevée dans les
établissements et services
médicaux-sociaux plus fortes en moyenne
que dans le BTP la Cour des comptes
estime inadapt le mode de tarification
dérogatoire qui leur est appliqué qui
n'est pas individualisé quelle que soit
la taille de la de l'établissement
concerné afin d'accroître les
incitations financières à la prévention
estimez-vous qu'il serait souhaitable
que leur soit appliqué le taux de
cotisation de droits commun mixte entre
20 et 149 salariés et individualisé
au-delà merci merci bien pour ces
questions précises Madame la Directrice
on vous laisse la
parole merci beaucoup alors je vais
reprendre effectivement vos vos
questions vous m'interrogez euh tout
d'abord sur la sinistralité
particulièrement chez le le la
population féminine au sein de la
population féminine et du coup ça
rejoint sans doute un peu votre dernière
question euh puisqu'on a un secteur
médico enfin sanitaire et médico-social
qui effectivement a une population
salariée très largement féminine avec
une exposition à des risques
professionnels de type troubl
musculossquelétique porort de charge
voilà qui sont
effectivement particulièrement fréquents
au sein d'une population féminine en
fonction de la de la moyenne d'âge de de
plus d'une quarantaine d'années sur ces
activités du secteur médico-social donc
je me permettrai de de vous répondre
conjointement sur cette première et
cette dernière question alors les pistes
que nous envisageons euh
le le tant la sinistralité au sein de la
population féminine en augmentation vous
l'avez dit et je partage cette
préoccupation que que celle du secteur
médico-social sont des sujets qui sont
pas totalement nouveaux sur lequel la
branche a déjà commencé à explorer mais
sur lequel aussi nous souhaitons on va
dire intensifier nos actions et
notamment dans les travaux que j'ai
évoqué tout de suite d'élaboration de la
prochaine période quinquenal enfin de
nos projets sur les CIN prochaines
années nous développons et nous
travaillons effectivement en ce moment
euh l'ingénierie d'une approche
sectorielle un peu particulière pour le
secteur médico-social de façon à adapter
notre communication vis-à-vis des
entreprises de ces secteurs notre
contractualisation aussi avec les
représentants des organisations
professionnelles qui sont très nombreux
sur un secteur qui est très large et qui
a une activité professionnelle très
hétérogène on ne travaille pas de la
même manière quand on travaille dans un
dans un épad de 200 salariés oou on aide
à domicile euh dans des petites
structures associatives donc on a ce
travail de de réflexion et d'ingénierie
pour trouver des solutions de prévention
adaptée et celles-ci sont de plusieurs
ordres alors là aussi selon qu'on
s'adresse à une très grande entreprise
un peu structurée ou à une entreprise
plus petite ces solutions de prévention
passent d'abord par
euh une démarche qui aujourd'hui
fonctionne parce qu'elle est
relativement ancienne et donc on a
maintenant presque une dizaine d'années
de recul sur ce déploiement c'est le
programme de la branche qui s'appelle
TMS pro et qui est un programme sur
lequel nous ciblons les entreprises les
plus sinistrogènes donc ça n'est pas
forcément une adhésion spontanée ou
volontaire les personnels de la branche
ATMP en en CARSAT vont solliciter les
entreprises de ces secteurs sanitaires
et médicaux-sociaux qui ont
historiquement des taux ou des
fréquences d'accis de travail
particulièrement élevé pour les inciter
les accompagner à cette adhésion à ce
programme qui est une adhésion de longue
haline puisque ça va durer plusieurs
années avec un vrai engagement du du du
directeur en tout cas de de des
entreprises concernées de ces instances
représentatif du personnel aujourd'hui
on sait que l'entrée dans ce programme
là qui fonctionne en plusieurs étapes
avec des réalisations de plan d'action
un accompagnement à l'évaluation des
risques je rentre pas dans dans tous les
détails mais on sait aujourd'hui qu'en 5
ans les entreprises qui ont adhéré à ce
programme et qui suivent ce programme en
passant les étapes voi baisser très
significativement leur sinistralité dans
tous les secteurs y compris dans le
secteur du médico-social puisqu'on avait
sur les 5 dernières années à peu près
1000 épad qui étaient suivis pour voir
si ça correspondait bien aux attentes on
sait aujourd'hui dire que oui la
sinistralité baisse pour les entreprises
qui adhèrent et même dans les secteurs
où la sinistralité a naturellement
baissé puisque ça pourrait être un biaet
elle baisse plus quand on adhère à ces
programmes donc on a aujourd'hui un
levier qui est important qui fonctionne
et et sur lequel sur les la prochaine
période en tout cas on va élargir les
nombre d'entreprises ciblé pour
accompagner les entrées dans ce
programme euh nous avons aussi pour des
entreprises peut-être de de structure un
peu plus
modestes des subventions prévention qui
permettent de mettre le pied à l'étrier
de cofinancer des achats d'équipement
pour aider par exemple à déplacer les
les patients malade éviter le port de
charge VO il y a des équipements
individuels qui peuvent être cofinancés
par la branche et puis vous l'avez dit
sur votre dernière question madame Gruny
il y a effectivement le meilleur levier
qui existe en matière de prévention
c'est le taux de cotisation c'est ce
qu'on appelle la mission tarification au
sein de la branche et vous l'avez dit
nous avons dans ce secteur médico-social
une particularité une dérogation en fait
à l'application du de la tarification de
droit commun puisque c'est un secteur
qui est soumis historiquement et
réglementairement à un taux collectif
systématique c'est-à-dire que même si on
a une grande entreprise qui fait
beaucoup d'efforts en prévention son
taux ne baisse pas contrairement aux
entreprises de plus de 150 salariés dans
le régime général sur une tarification
de droit commun et à contrario une
entreprise qui serait particulièrement
sinistrogène avec une fréquence
particulièrement élevé ne verrait pas
son taux de cotisation augmenté donc ça
n'est pas incitatif c'est ce ce ce
développement aussi de ce caractère
incitatif à la prévention fait également
partie des sujets de tarification qui
sont devant nous que nous évoquons
régulièrement nous avons régulièrement
évoqué avec les partenaires sociaux de
la branche sur cette précédente période
que nous remettons sur la table pour
pour la période quinquinal qui s ouvre
avec effectivement le souhait en tout
cas côté knarm très très fortement
exprimé d'avancer sur ce sujet-là
notamment pour ce secteur parce que bien
évidemment investir financièrement dans
des investissements en prévention
marchera si on entre dans une logique
vertueuse en matière de
cotisation donc le sujet reste reste
devant nous sur ce sur ce point-là et
vous évoquez enfin
euh le phénomène de
sousdéclaration j'insiste un sur sous
déclaration et non pas sous
reconnaissance euh alors vous vous le
savez mais je crois que la question
effectivement comme vous l'évoquez avait
été posée à Thomas fatô la semaine
dernière ça n'est pas la CNAM qui fixe
le montant de la de la sous-déclaration
c'est une commission qui est composée de
de compétences scientifique médical
statistique qui se réunit tous les 3 ans
qui va d'ailleurs se se reprendre ses
travaux l'année prochaine sous l'égide
de la Cour des comptes et puis ensuite
le gouvernement retient une fourchette
et en l'occurrence retient une
fourchette basse dans les évaluations de
la cour Cours des comptes sur ces
montantsl c'est juste objectif voilà et
effectivement euh donc au-delà de ce de
ce sujet de de fixation de montant pour
le coup sur lequel la CNAM n'est pas
n'est pas opérateur euh comme l'évoquait
je crois Thomas Fatom la semaine
dernière nous nous expérimentons des
actions de l'ordre de l'allé vert je je
pense dont vous avez largement discuté
au sein de cette commission en matière
de de détection de l'origine
professionnelle des pathologies qui
seraient euh diagnostiqué euh entre un
patient et son et son médecin et son
prescripteur nous avons lancé une une
action de détection de ce type-là et
nous sommes en train de de toujours de
de de lancer cette action auprès d'à peu
près
3000 assurés l'idée étant de
sélectionner des pathologies sur
lesquels on a normalement une origine
professionnelle assez fréquente par
exemple la surdité ou l'asthme selon
l'âge des patients peut-être et
l'activité professionnelle évidemment
des patients peut-être assez fréquemment
lié à une origine professionnelle et on
on se rend compte qu'en fait ça n'est
peu le cas en déclaration on se doute
qu'on a un potentiel et c'est c'est
aussi les travaux de la commission qui
nous le qui nous le montre de surdité
d'origine professionnelle qui pourrait
être beaucoup plus fréquent et donc
mieux pris en charge au bénéfice
évidemment des assurés ou de leurs ayant
droit puisque vous savez que les
conditions de prise en charge de la
branche at sont plus plus intéressantes
qu' qu'en maladie donc nous avons ciblé
quelques pathologies et sur quelques
régions là où l'activité économique dans
ses spécificités euh permettre
d'imaginer qu'il peut y avoir un lien
plus plus fort par exemple de fortes
activités liées au bois ou à la
menuiserie pour un cancer naso sinuséen
je vous donne un exemple un peu concret
et donc on a ciblé des assurés
qui pouvaient être concernés par une
pathologie de ce type et potentiellement
d'origine professionnelle avec un simple
courrier informatif à ce stade et nous
avons des résultats je dois je dois bien
l'avouer relativement décevants c'est
que notre le courrier de l'assurance
maladie ne suffit pas à générer un
échange avec le médecin traitant ou une
recherche de de de renseignement et
encore moins une un dépôt de déclaration
donc nous continuons à expérimenter en
essayant en et c'est le cas en ce moment
de plutôt contacter non seulement
l'assurée mais également le médecin
prescripteur alors ce qui nous fait
rentrer dans des évidemment des
contraintes et des exigences bien
légitimes de respect de de gestion des
données sensibles à forcerie médical
donc c'est le service médical de
l'assurance maladie qui qui prend en
charge cette partie-là pour essayer
d'avoir à la fois une sensibilisation et
du prescripteur et du patient de manière
conjointe euh voilà nous avons d'autres
pistes expérimentales dans d'autres
régions avec l'aide d'ailleurs des CAES
primaires d'assurance maladie sur le
terrain qui peuvent nous aider à trouver
des des moyens d'être plus précis dans
nos sollicitation d'assuré mais là aussi
le le le le travail est en cours sur ces
sujets-là et et je n'ai pas encore de
résultats probants pour améliorer cette
cette
détection bien merci Madame directrice
vous aviez terminé votre intervention
très bien maintenant je vais donner la
parole à de nos collègues d'abord Cathy
poursoui bonjour madame et merci euh
tout d'abord on on sent actuellement une
vive colère euh de la part de la FNAT de
l'endeva mais on aura
l'occasion de les auditionner notamment
sur l'article 39 qui prévoit de revenir
sur un un arrêt de la Cour de cassation
concernant l'indemnisation des accidents
du travail et des maladies
professionnelles jusqu'en janvier les
victimes étaient donc indemnisées de
manière forfaitaire euh et pour couvrir
donc la perte de l'organ professionnel
mais aussi l'incidence professionnelle
de l'incapacité euh et puis évidemment
s'ajouter à ça le déficit fonctionnel
que que pensez-vous de ce retour en
arrière à
finalement où nombre d'associations nous
contactent en nous disant que ce n'est
pas possible de revenir en arrière sur
un article de la Cour de cassation je
vous
remercie madame
leérou merci monsieur le Président alors
moi j'avais une question concernant les
conséquences de la réforme des retraites
plus de seniors donc vont se retrouver
au travail avez-vous travaillé plus
précisément sur l'impact de de ces
mesures y a-t-il des mesures de
prévention particulière de communication
auprès des entreprises d'une part pour
évaluer plus précisément donc l'impact
mais aussi pour prendre des mesures de
prévention et puis une deuxième question
qui
concerne les arrêts de travail de de
longue durée la Cour des comptes avait
avait point il y a quelques années euh
des la nécessité de mettre en place des
mesures d'accompagnement à la reprise de
de travail est-ce que vous pouvez
aujourd'hui faire un un bilan de de ces
mesures que vous avez été amené à
prendre et de leur efficacité
merci merci beaucoup alors effectivement
pour revenir sur l'article 39 et pardon
je je suis passé un petit peu vite euh
mais effectivement il est important
qu'on y qu'on y revienne donc première
première
partie il y a effectivement et nous
avons bien sûr suivi les les les débats
que que suscite la rédaction de cet
article 39 et au-delà de la rédaction
évidemment ce que ça signifie sur le
fond alors pour resituer pour resituer
les choses j'ai envie de dire que le le
la notion de retour arrière dépend un
peu de la date à laquelle qu'on prend
comme référence parce qu'
effffectivement c'est un sujet qui qui
qui tourne depuis pas mal d'années en
fait historiquement et depuis plus d'une
dizaine d'années la Cour de cassation
incite tous les ans dans son rapport le
législateur a amélioré globalement le
niveau d'indemnisation des rentiers
indemnisés par la branche ATMP et une
jurisprudence ENF et jusqu'à présent
pardon et jusqu'à janvier 2023 on
considérait globalement que la rente
indemnisée plusieurs types de préjudices
à la fois le déficit fonctionnel
permanent c'est-à-dire l'extra
professionnel pour faire cours et euh la
perte de de gain professionnel ou
l'incidence professionnelle donc de
manière assez global voilà la
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation en
2023 précise effectivement que la rente
ne couvre que le déficit professionnel
enfin la perte de chance professionnelle
renvoyant toute l'indemnisation euh de
l'extra professionnel à euh au recours
potentiel des assurés en justice pour un
recours en faute inexcusable de
l'employeur euh alors ce qui a un
avantage certain pour les assurés qui
font ces recours là c'est
qu'effectivement faire reconnaître
l'indemnisation complète de toute la
partie non professionnelle en fie c'est
une indemnisation très conséquente de la
rente qui se se déclenche à ce moment-là
encore faut-il un avoir les moyens de
faire ce recours et deux qu'il soit
reconnu et je vous disais tout à l'heure
nous avions à peu près 30000 nouveaux
rentiers chaque année il y a à peu près
3000 assurés qui font un recours qui
déposent un recours et il n'y en a que
1600 qui l'obtiennent donc vous voyez le
le le la proportion ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a 1600 assurés qui
peuvent faire un recours en fie et le
gagner et donc obtenir une indemnisation
de ce déficit fonctionnel permanent cet
article 39 effectivement n'est pas ne ne
suit pas à la lettre la jurisprudence de
la Cour de cassation parce qu'il tient
aussi compte de la position de la
gouvernance de la branche qui est aussi
celle de de fond de la du compromis
historique de la branche qui est de dire
que la réparation en ATMP est
forfaitaire et cet article 39 dit la
nature de la branche la nature de la
rente pardon reste bien dual donc on
intègre bien le DFP dans la dans le
déficit fonctionnel permanent
pardon en plus de la du déficit
professionnel dans la nature même de la
rente ce qui effectivement et et ce qui
explique les réactions effectivement des
défenseurs des assurés que vous que vous
citez euh qui disent mais du coup quand
on a une faute inexcusable de
l'employeur il n'y a plus toute
l'indemnisation du DFP puisqu'il est
dans la rente initialement et donc il y
a potentiellement une perte
d'indemnisation en cas de
fie ce à quoi il faut voir également et
je je porterai évidemment pas de de
jugement de valeur sur ce sujet-là mais
il faut voir que potentiellement
peut-être que cette indemnisation à fie
va diminuer mais aujourd'hui rien ne
permet de l'assurer puisque les barêes
de calcul ne sont pas écrits ces barêes
sont laissés à la cons conertation
sociale sur les mois qui
viennent effectivement on peut
comprendre que l'intégration d'une
partie du déficit fonctionnel permanent
dans la rente fait qu'il ne sera pas
indemnisé deux fois donc il sera moins
indemnisé en cas de fie mais il sera
indemnisé pour autant pour tous les
rentiers c'est-à-dire pour les 30000
nouveaux rentiers et c'est là où il y a
de fait une indemnisation supplémentaire
dans l'indemnisation de la rente pour
tous les rentier puisqu'on y ajoute
l'indemnisation d'un préjudice qui n'y
est pas en tout cas qui n'y est plus
depuis janvier 2023 et encore une fois
avant de pouvoir faire des calculs
précis de ce qui va baisser ou ce qui va
monter il faut laisser la place à cette
concertation qui est devant nous sur
quel barê on utilise pour le déficit
professionnel et quel barême on utilise
pour le déficit fonctionnel pour le
déficit fonctionnel on a tendance à se
rapprocher spontanément des des barêmes
de droit civil qui existent aujourd'hui
qui sont relativement intéressants pour
les pour les assurer mais ce travail làà
de calcul fin est devant nous puisque
l'article 39 renvoie à ce temps de
concertation alors certes un peu
contraint puisqu'il doit être mis en
place au 1er janvier 2025
voilà j'espère avoir répondu cette fois
plus complètement sur ce sujet pardon
vous m' interrogz sur les igiS de longue
durée
également alors c'est une action que
nous avons mené historiquement un peu
avant la crise sanitaire donc il
commence à dater maintenant de plusieurs
années et que nous réactivons maintenant
donc je n'ai pas les résultats
aujourd'hui mais pour vous vous
expliquer de quoi de quoi il s'agit vous
le savez sans doute pour indemnisation
de l'incapacité temporaire en matière
d'atmp il y a effectivement pas de de
date de fin ou de délai contrairement au
maladie o au bout de 3 ans on ne perçoit
plus d'indemnité journalière en ATMP il
n'y a pas de de date de fin parce que
par principe l'état de santé de la
victime peut être long à être ce qu'on
appelle consolidé une fois qu'une
victime d'un accident de travail et ou
maladie professionnelle est consolidée
alors on peut ouvrir s'il reste des
séquels sur une rente mais tant qu'elle
n'est pas consolidée elle reste
indemnisée en en incapacité
temporaire nous requéons régulièrement
et donc c'est c'est c'est ce que nous
réactivons aujourd'hui en terme
d'opération sur l'ensemble de nos
assurés pour quand même mettre un peu
sous surveillance des assurés qui
seraient depuis très longtemps indemnisé
au titre de l'incapacité temporaire ne
serait-ce que pour s'assurer que leur
état de santé n'est pas consolidé et
qu'ils n'ont pas été ils sont pas passés
à travers les trous de la raquette
pardonnez-moi cette expression pour être
vu par le médecin conseil de l'assurance
maladie et potentiellement consolidé
nous avons quand même 1500 situation he
aujourd'hui d'assurer qu'ils sont en un
capacité permanente de plus de 5 ans ce
qui est quand même relativement long
alors ça peut s'expliquer encore une
fois par des états de santé très
particuliers mais ça me semble normal
pour ces assurés là en tout cas de de
diligenter une une convocation auprès du
service médical pour qu'un médecin
conseil de l'Assurance Maladie puisse
faire le point de leur état de santé et
c'est faire le point sans préjuger de la
suite voilà encore une fois il y a des
situations tout à fait justifiées sur
ces situationsl et si on peut consolider
un état de santé et ouvrir droit à une
rente je pense que c'est aussi aussi
bien pour le pour le salarié voilà sur
ce sujet là vous aviez une autre
question sur les
conséences alors je je l'évoquais
effectivement rapidement tout à l'heure
il y a deux mesures en particulier alors
deux voir trois mesures en particulier
qui sont prévues au sein du PLFSS sur ce
sujet-là
euh d'abord un élargissement des des de
l'accès au au comptes professionnels de
prévention donc le C2P qui est l'ancien
dispositif pénibilité pour ceux qui l'en
qui le connaissent qui l'ont suivi euh
alors qui qui ne s'applique pas selon
des critères d'âge au sens de Senior
mais qui s'applique évidemment à des
critères ou à des facteurs de risque
professionnel renforcés par exemple le
travail de nuit ou le travail en équipe
alternante et ces conditions-là qui
permettent de cumuler des points et
ensuite d'ouvrir droit en particulier
puisque c'est le la solution qui est la
plus souvent retenue à une majoration de
durée d'assurance qui permet de partir
enentaite de manière un peu anticipée
euh ont des conditions euh qui sont
aujourd'hui abaissées euh et
l'évaluation financière qui en est faite
euh à la charge de la branche puisque la
branche at rembourse la branche retraite
sur ce sujet-là à hauteur d'une
vingtaine de millions d'euros par an euh
donc à répercuter évidemment sur les
années qui viennent première mesure
une deuxième mesure concerne le fond
d'investissement pour la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle donc on est là
aussi pas forcément sur un accès par
critère d'âge mais un accès par métier
exposant
particulièrement au risques ergonomiques
donc port de charge manutention
vibration et ce fond est alimenté par
les excédents de la branche à hauteur de
200 millions par an en année pleine avec
l'idée de d'aider les entreprises à
financer ou de financer complètement des
actions de prévention de ces risques
alors qui peuvent être des achats
d'équipement pour soulager je je je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure le port de
charge par exemple ou des actions liées
à l'investissement dans un préventeur au
sein de l'entreprise pour travailler sur
ces sur ces sujetsl ou encore faire des
diagnostics ou des évaluations de risque
donc toutes ces évaluations là ou des
aménagements de poste de travail euh
toutes ces actionsl euh bah sont
financées sur le sur la branche et
rentrent je pense dans votre votre
préoccupation euh il y a également et à
hauteur de 25eur 25 millions d'euros par
an euh également dans les dans les
estimations financières du PLFSS une
mesure liée à l'élargissement des accès
à la retraite pour incapacité permanente
qui permet pour les victimes d'atmp
euh de rester sur une retraite anticipée
par rapport à l'âge légal euh et enfin
une dernière mesure qui est liée plus
spécifiquement à l'emploi des seniors et
qui lié au fait que pour les les assurés
qui ont une maladie professionnelle à
effet
différé pour ne pas faire peser
potentiellement le charge de
l'imputation au compte employeur des
derniers employeurs des assurés en
question et si on parle de maladie
professionnelle à effet différé par
principe on est plutôt sur des salariés
âgés qui déclarent malheureusement des
maladies professionnelles type cancer
professionnel dans la dans la durée or
aujourd'hui nous imputons ces maladie
professionnelle au compte du dernier
employeur exposant du dernier employeur
voilà exposant mais sans forcément
remonter à la charge de la preuve et là
il y aura une mutualisation de ce coup
là donc pour faire simple l'idée est de
ne pas faire reposer de manière
individualiser l'employeur qui
souhaiterait embaucher un salarié senior
qui aurait potentiellement été dans des
activités exposantes la charge d'une
déclaration éventuelle de maladie
professionnelle par ce salarié voilà
l'ensemble du panorama des mesures qui
correspondent je pense à votre
préoccupation merci j'ai une autre
demande de parole donc Ann Sophie Romani
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice j'ai posé une question la
semaine dernière à Monsieur fatô dont la
réponse ne m'a pas été satisfaisante
j'espère avoir un peu plus de chance
avec vous je vais vous reposer la
question je me tourne aujourd'hui vers
vous pour avoir quelques informations
sur le burnout qui génère beaucoup d'é
il ne faut pas confondre le syndrome
d'épuisement et une simple fatigue je
voulais savoir s'il existait des
critères pour mesurer le burnout
aujourd'hui quel était la manière de
contrôler les burnout et je voulais
savoir combien ça coûtait aujourd'hui un
burnout dans notre société parce qu'on a
quand même voilà pas mal de on entend
c'est un mot qu'on entend
souvent je vous laisse répondre à cette
question avec plaisir merci Madame eu
alors je il y a plusieurs questions dans
votre question d'abord effectivement
c'est un c'est un sujet que la branche
indemnise alors on par parle-nous de
troubles
psychosociaux de manière plus globale le
burnout en soi n'est pas un diagnostic
médical il regroupe évidemment une toute
une myiade de pathologie ou de
diagnostic mais mais voilà les
compétences je n'ai pas de compéten
médical sur ce point donc je je je
reprend les éléments les éléments du du
sujet la
reconnaissance des troubles
psychosociaux d'origine professionnelle
est effectivement un sujet important
dans la branche à deux titres d'abord on
a toujours on pense spontanément à la
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle autour de dépression par
exemple ou de syndrome d'anxiété euh et
forcé de constater que pour la prise en
charge de maladies professionnell au
sein de la branche il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de tableau qui est de
maladie professionnelle qui permettrait
une reconnaissance automatisée ou en
tout cas avec des critères normés c'est
sans doute la particularité de ces
troubles d'avoir du mal aussi à rentrer
dans des critères normés vous l'évoquz
en terme de critères euh donc on passe
aujourd'hui les salariés aujourd'hui
doivent passer par un comité d'experts
médicaux qui se prononceront sur le lien
entre la pathologie ou le trouble
constaté et l'origine professionnelle et
il faut pour cela avoir au moins 25 %
d'incapacité permanente donc il y a un
filtrage relativement important sur la
proconnaissance et la prise en charge en
maladie professionnelle de ces troubles
et c'est à peu près de mémoire 2000
dossiers par an que la brance ATMP prend
en charge au titre de l'origine
professionnelle de ces maladies
professionnelles par ailleurs au titre
des accident de travail la branche
reconnaît pour le coup de manière
beaucoup plus importante en volume ces
situationsl donc on est plutôt sur une
une définition un peu différente de de
ces de ces RPS de ces risques
psychosociaux et là on est plutôt autour
de 12000 reconnaissance en accident de
travail par an voilà donc si je cumule
on est à peu près sur une situation
prise en charge par la branche de 15000
situations par an et il faut il faut
noter que c'est une une courbe
croissante de prise en charge euh de la
la branche j'évoqué tout à l'heure qu'on
était sur une sinistralité globalement à
tendance baissière depuis une dizaine
d'années ça n'est pas le cas de ces
risques psychos-ociaux qui sont
effectivement euh de plus en plus
reconnus et pris en charge encore une
fois soit au titre de maladie
professionnell soit au titre d'accident
de travail euh donc on a évidemment un
positionnement et un engagement fort de
la branche sur ce sur ce sujet-là
euh y compris d'ailleurs dans nos nos
projets puisque nous nous travaillons
aujourd'hui à un programme je vous
parlais du programme national de de
lutte contre les TMS tout à l'heure qui
était efficace en matière de diminution
de la
sinistralité nous menons également des
actions pour d'une part inscrire un
programme national de prévention des RPS
demain dans notre convention d'objectifs
et de gestion mais tout de suite nous
avons
engagé des actions sur le sujet et je
crois que monsieur fatau vous en a parlé
lors de l'audition parce que j'ai
regardé le Replay qui est une action qui
s'appelle lutte contre l'absentéisme
atypique en entreprise vous en a
peut-être parlé pour un autre motif mais
et les RPS font également partie des
sujets pour lesquels nous identifions
des entreprises au sein desquelles il y
a un un absentéisme particulièrement
fort et donc on comptabilise he les les
les journées d'indemnité journalière et
maladie et ATMP et en fonction d'une
corrélation avec la consommation de
soins il y a pas de données médicales
sur le sujet on est évidemment très
prudent on est capable de revenir à
l'entreprise et de signifier quand c'est
le cas qu'elle a un absentéisme deux à
trois fois supérieur à la moyenne des
entreprises de son secteur soit pour des
sujets de TMS lombalgie soit sur des
sujet de RPS et c'est là où ça devient
intéressant alors on démarre hein le le
le sujet mais on a quand même des
résultats tout à fait intéressants
d'abord de prise de conscience des des
dirigeants d'entreprisees et derrière
avec une capacité à leur dire euh il y a
pas de fatalité sur ces sujets-là que ce
soit d'origine professionnelle ou non et
évidemment en matière de troubles
psychosociaux on est sur un champ qui
est vous l'avez dit hein avec des
critères qui sont pas totalement
évidents il existe et la branche at en
tout cas peut vous proposer des
démarches de prévention qui sont adaptés
qui vont travailler sur le mode de
management sur l'organisation du travail
donner des clés simples alors que vous
pourrez retrouver par exemple sur le
site de l'ENRS qui est le laboratoire
scientifique de la branche et qui a pas
mal publié et documenté la prévention
des RPS dans les dans les
entreprises et puis enfin en terme de
critères les choses quand même se
documentent là aussi de plus en plus il
y a un rapport golac notamment
qui date il y a quelques années qui qui
est voilà une une démarche en tout cas
de critérisation qui peut être
relativement utile et assez concrète
pour se poser les questions et évaluer
le risque RPS en entreprise qui est
évidemment la première étape de toute
démarche de prévention c'est évidemment
d'arriver à évaluer précisément la
nature du risque auquel sont confrontés
les
salariés merci Madame la Directrice il
n'y a plus de demande de prise de parole
en tous les cas on va de nouveau rétirer
nos remerciements pour votre
intervention de ce matin et donc nous
allons continuer à travailler sur
l'analyse notamment de cette branche
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS bonne
journée à
tous